Traducteur: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je suis contente d'être ici.
Je suis ici en tant que biologiste
pour vous parler d'un domaine
de la biologie qui est vraiment nouveau,
bien qu'il ait ses bases au 17ème siècle,
avec Jean-Baptiste de Lamarck,
mais c'est un domaine de la biologie
qui est révolutionnaire,
et qui va, je pense aussi, permettre
des progrès en médecine rapides,
et des progrès qui ne seraient
peut-être pas possibles
avec ce genre de biologie.
J’espère que dans mes hypothèses,
il y en a pas trop qui seront fausses,
(Rires)
et que je ne vais pas faire
trop d'erreurs.
Nous sommes tous constitués
de milliards de cellules,
et chaque cellule contient
notre bagage génétique.
Donc, chaque cellule a un noyau
qui contient 23 paires de chromosomes,
et ces chromosomes
sont faits de filaments d'ADN,
et c'est la séquence de l'ADN
qui fait les gènes.
Donc on a entre environ
20 000 et 25 000 gènes,
et c'est ce qui fait notre inné,
c'est-à-dire notre bagage génétique,
qu'on hérite en partie
de notre mère et de notre père.
L'inné nous donne
certaines caractéristiques,
et fait en partie ce que nous sommes.
Mais en fait, on est beaucoup plus
que juste nos gènes.
Notre acquis, les expériences de vie,
les environnements auxquels
on est exposé pendant toute notre vie,
sont aussi très importants,
et déterminent notre personnalité,
notre bonne santé,
notre sensibilité aux maladies,
et même jusqu'à notre longévité
ou notre durée de vie.
Or, il y a plein de circonstances,
ou d’expériences de vie,
qui nous influencent.
Que ce soit des circonstances
positives ou négatives,
l'alimentation, les médicaments,
l'alcool, le tabac,
les pollutions environnementales,
les agents toxiques,
le plastique, j'en parlerais
un petit peu plus tard.
Ces agents, ces expériences
de vie également,
peuvent affecter toutes
les cellules dans nos corps.
Que ce soit les cellules du cerveau,
ou les cellules du cœur,
ou même les cellules germinales,
les cellules reproductrices.
Et en fait, ces expériences nous affectent
tout au cours de la vie,
mais tout particulièrement
pendant l'enfance, et l'adolescence,
parce que notre corps
est en pleine formation,
et les cellules sont extrêmement
sensibles à l’environnement.
Or, il est clair que l'inné, nos gènes,
sont transmis à travers les générations.
Maintenant, on peut se poser
la question, ou l'hypothèse,
est-ce que nos acquis
peuvent également être transmis ?
Est-ce que par exemple
ce que ce grand-père a vécu,
s'il a été exposé à un traumatisme
de guerre, admettons,
qui a eu des effets forts
sur sa personnalité,
sur sa sensibilité aux maladies,
ou l'a rendu dépressif par exemple,
est-ce que ce sont des acquis
qu'il pourrait transmettre
à ses enfants et à ses petits-enfants.
C'est une question qui peut sembler
un petit peu bizarre, ou incongrue,
parce que, dans la pensée normale,
le dogme en biologie
est que c'est par les gènes
que les choses sont transmises,
et c'est une idée qui est admise,
parce qu'il y a des tonnes
de caractères qu'on acquiert,
ou de dysfonctions
de l'organisme ou de maladies,
qui sont dues à l'environnement, et sont
transmises sur plusieurs générations.
Donc c'est un concept
qui a évolué énormément,
mais dont la base biologique
reste encore assez floue.
Alors si on émet cette hypothèse,
quels sont les mécanismes possibles ?
On sait que pour qu'il y ait
transmission à travers les générations,
il faut que les cellules germinales,
les cellules reproductrices,
soient affectées.
Or, les cellules, en particulier
les cellules reproductrices,
en plus du bagage génétique,
ont un bagage épigénétique.
C'est-à-dire, toute une série
de marques biochimiques
qui sont sur l'ADN, ou près de l'ADN,
qui le modifient, et qui, en fait,
déterminent l'activité des gènes,
déterminent si un gène est actif ou pas.
Les gènes sans les marques épigénétiques
ne font rien, sont inutiles.
Il existe plusieurs
marques épigénétiques :
parmi les plus importantes,
il y a la méthylation de l'ADN,
se sont des résidus méthyl
qui se fixent sur l'ADN
à des endroits bien précis,
il y a des ARNs non-codants,
des types ou des grandes molécules d'ARNs,
qui existent à proximité de l'ADN,
qui peut aussi fixer
et le contrôler, le régler.
Maintenant si on se pose la question :
est-ce que les marques épigénétiques
peuvent être modifiées
par l’environnement ?
Pourraient-elles être responsables
de phénotypes comportementaux,
par exemple la dépression,
que j'ai déjà mentionnée,
si c'est le cas, est-ce qu'elles
peuvent garder en mémoire,
ou garder une mémoire d’expérience de vie,
qui ont des effets négatifs ou positifs,
de façon à le transmettre
à travers des générations ?
Alors pour tester cette hypothèse,
on doit avoir recours à un modèle
expérimental de laboratoire,
parce que ce n'est pas possible de tester
ce genre d'hypothèses sur l'être humain,
et la souris de laboratoire
est un excellent modèle
pour plusieurs raisons.
D'abord, on peut sélectionner les souris
de façon à ce qu'elles soient
homogènes au niveau génétique.
On a des souches de souris qui ont
absolument exactement les mêmes gènes.
Ça permet, si on s'intéresse
aux marques épigénétiques,
d'éliminer la variabilité génétique,
toutes ont les mêmes gènes,
on peut maintenant bien étudier
les différences de marques épigénétiques.
Un autre avantage de la souris est que,
la durée des générations
est relativement courte.
Une souris est adulte
à environ 2, 3 mois,
et on peut générer la progéniture
sur plusieurs générations.
En tout cas dans la vie d'un chercheur,
c'est difficile, c'est long,
c'est coûteux, mais c'est faisable.
Un dernier avantage des souris
est que si on veut les exposer
à un environnement particulier,
ou à une expérience particulière,
on peut le faire de façon
contrôlée et reproductible.
Donc avoir des grands groupes
et les soumettre à la même expérience.
Bon, c'est ce qu'on a fait
dans mon laboratoire,
tout particulièrement autour
de la question des traumatismes précoces,
on a mis au point un protocole,
qui dépend de la séparation maternelle
imprévisible, quotidienne.
C'est un protocole
qui traumatise les souriceaux,
pendant les premières semaines de vie.
Ça correspondrait chez l'homme
à 2/3 de l'enfance,
C'est la séparation maternelle
imprévisible quotidienne,
couplée à du stress maternel imprévisible.
Donc c'est une manipulation
traumatique émotionnelle et physique.
Ensuite, on étudie les conséquences
sur le comportement, sur le métabolisme
et sur le fonctionnement général,
à travers les générations,
en croisant les animaux
avec les animaux contrôles
de façon à générer
la 1e, la 2e, la 3e génération.
On s'est intéressé tout
particulièrement au comportement.
Chez l'homme, c'est connu,
dans la littérature,
en psychiatrie clinique,
qu'être confronté à des traumatismes
dans l'enfance
donne souvent des profils
de dépression à l'âge adulte.
On peut tester
la dépression chez la souris.
Un test qui a été mis
au point dans les années 70,
un test de nage forcée.
Ça consiste à mettre un animal
dans un récipient d'eau froide.
Vous le voyez sur la gauche :
une souris normale, qui nage.
Elle essaye de s'échapper.
Sur la droite, une souris dépressive,
qui flotte.
Or, les animaux qui ont été soumis
à ce traumatisme de séparation,
de stress maternel,
sont dépressifs et ça,
sur plusieurs générations.
Même les arrières-petits-enfants,
qui n'ont pas été en contact
avec les mâles qui ont été traumatisés,
même si on les fait adopter
par d'autres femelles,
ils sont aussi dépressifs
que leur arrière-grand-père.
Donc ça indique qu'il y a
une transmission vis-à-vis du stress.
Pour revenir
à notre hypothèse cellulaire,
est-ce que ceci s'accompagne
d'une modification des marques
épigénétiques sur les jumeaux ?
Oui : on a examiné ça sur les gamètes,
les spermatozoïdes en particulier,
dans les neurones.
Et on a observé qu'il y avait une
méthylation de l'ADN qui est aberrante,
il y a trop de méthylation sur certains
gènes et pas assez sur d'autres,
et les ARN non-codants sont en excès,
de façon assez importante.
Maintenant, c'est une bonne indication
que les marques épigénétiques peuvent
être modifiées par l'environnement,
mais ce n'est pas la preuve finale.
Pour prouver vraiment
que ces marques épigénétiques
sont responsables
de la transmission d'effets du traumatisme
sur des générations,
il faudrait être capable
de reproduire ces altérations.
Or, pour la méthylation de l'ADN,
techniquement, ce n'est pas possible,
parce que, dans ce cas-là,
la méthylation est trop abondante
à certains endroits et absente à d'autres,
donc techniquement parlant,
ce n'est pas faisable de nos jours.
Par contre, reproduire un excès d'ARN
dans un embryon,
c'est tout à fait faisable.
Donc c'est une chose
qu'on a mise au point.
On a tout d'abord extrait les ARN
de cellules de spermatozoïdes
de mâles traumatisés,
qu'on a injectés dans des ovules-contrôles
fertilisés par
des spermatozoïdes-contrôles.
Donc là, on a un futur embryon,
qui est complètement normal,
il contient simplement l'ARN
de spermatozoïdes de mâles traumatisés.
Après injection, on prend
les ovules injectés,
et on les transfère dans des
femelles préparées hormonalement,
par chirurgie,
et on attend que la femelle mette bas,
on attend que les animaux
deviennent adultes,
et on teste leur comportement.
Ce qu'on a observé, c'est que les animaux
issus de ces œufs injectés
sont tout aussi dépressifs
que les mâles dont on a extrait l'ARN,
et également leur progéniture.
Ce qui apporte la preuve
que l'ARN des cellules germinales
est un indicateur de la transmission
des effets du traumatisme.
Quelles sont les retombées
de ce genre de recherches
pour l'homme ? pour la médecine ?
En psychiatrie, on nous a dit
que c'est connu
qu'être exposé à des traumatismes
comme des accidents, des violences,
la maltraitance, l'abandon,
-- la maltraitance, mais ça peut
être aussi l'humiliation,
des mauvais rapports
entre parents et enfants,
qui empêchent l'enfant de se développer,
psychiquement parlant, normalement,
ça peut conduire à des maladies
comme la dépression, la schizophrénie,
des troubles du comportement,
même jusque des suicides,
et qu'on sait que ces maladies
sont transmises à travers les générations.
Malgré des centaines, voire des milliers,
d'études génétiques,
on n'a encore pas trouvé
le gène de la dépression,
ni celui de la schizophrénie.
C'est parce que ces maladies
sont surtout dues
à des expositions environnementales
à des mécanismes épigénétiques.
De même, de nombreuses études
sur des descendants d'enfants,
qui ont été conçus ou qui ont vécu
pendant des périodes de grande famine,
comme la 2e Guerre Mondiale,
en Suède et en Hollande,
les descendants de ces enfants-là
ont une incidence supérieure
de maladies cardio-vasculaires,
d'obésité, de diabète,
et ça, sur plusieurs générations.
Il y a aussi de plus en plus d'exemples
des conséquences
de l'exposition aux pesticides,
dont de nombreux sont
des perturbateurs endocriniens,
qui ont des conséquences
sur plusieurs générations.
Et également les plastiques alimentaires,
ceux qui contiennent du bisphénol-A,
on sait maintenant que les effets peuvent
être transmis à travers les générations.
Quand je vous disais que
c'est un domaine de la biologie
assez révolutionnaire,
émergent,
difficile conceptuellement
et pratiquement,
-- je sais que beaucoup de découvertes
se font par hasard,
mais en l'occurrence,
ce n'est pas le cas,
on est obligé d'avoir des plans
expérimentaux détaillés, précis,
sur des générations,
donc ça demande énormément de temps,
mais je pense que ce genre de recherches,
malgré toute la difficulté,
est prometteur.
Je suis moi-même particulièrement
engagée dans ce genre de recherches.
J'espère que nos résultats, un jour, vont
pouvoir apporter des réponses
aux questions qu'on se pose
dans différents domaines,
la psychiatrie,
-- je m'y intéresse particulièrement --
métabolismes et cancers,
beaucoup de cancers sont
dus aux traitements environnementaux,
et que j'espère que nos résultats pourront
aider au développement de diagnostics
ou d'approches thérapeutiques
dans le futur.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)